this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
there's why the including the pride is
such a firm favorite
[Music]
how insane was that everybody and
welcome to the 13th episode of Safari
lives our weekly highlights package from
the week that was here at juma private
game reserve the western kruger national
park and of course the Mara triangle in
the Maasai Mara my name is James Hendry
and I'm currently being blinded by the
Sun that is going down behind me since
all is on camera and we'd love to hear
from you during the course of the show
using the hashtags for libel the chat
stream on YouTube over there we have got
some elephants the elephants have got
very little to do with the show that we
have this afternoon a show in which
around Juma the cats were running hither
and yon
[Music]
[Music]
so you can see it's been quite an
interesting cat week and not a lot of
elephants on that map but the cats have
been moving around there is an elephant
who's sort of trying to eat from some
fresh flush it has just come on the
second of spring yes is he's very upset
you can see didn't feature in the map
and so now he is offended deeply so once
we have had a good look at these
elephants we will probably introduce you
to a new character very diminutive
character and then we'll go on the
search for Tandy and Columba and see if
we can't find the cat terminating at the
end of the tracks that Herbert and
Sidney were following not Herbert and
Sidney Herbert and Tristan were
following earlier today beautiful young
elephant bald here in front of us nice
James who says so nice to have Safari
licenses back I'm very pleased that you
enjoying Safari lives we quite enjoyed
to and that's because it really does
give us a nice round up and it helps us
to tell the story of our cats it helps
us to really in detail and pack the
goings-on in their lives and then also
to discuss with you what you think's
happening because of course nothing out
here is definite we don't know anything
for dead certain about what's going on
in the minds of our favorite cat
characters and so it's always great to
debate with you as to what's happening
and yes with you this is a very touchy
elephant you can see you now wants to
know exactly what's happening with our
kept characters where they are and why
he has not been included
he's a touchy young bull probably aged
around about who I'm gonna say 14 years
or so just when young men would start to
get touchy as well come on then come say
hello
there you are this is very special yes
Angela it does amaze me to how they
munch on dry old sticks but you can see
when they don't have to munch on dry old
sticks they won't they will munch on
grass and greenery that's a read of some
description that he's found there and he
was eating on what looks like a splendid
thorn that bright green tree that's just
flushed yeah I think that's pretty much
what it is I think it's a splint thorn
so a few of the trees have started to
flush their great fresh green now what
he's doing here is pretending to eat
this is what's known as displacement
behaviour so he doesn't really want us
to think that he's paying too much
attention to us but at the same time he
definitely is paying only attention to
us he's now pretending to eat stones and
sniff little sticks and see they're
about that
he's much more interested in us and TV
goes down here no this is fantastic
because it really is amazing how agile
these elephants are now this is a
tremendously steep Bank the do as a
human being would think twice about just
trying to walk down he's removing all of
Rick's ins anti erosion control which is
not ideal Erickson will have a word with
him a little later and the rest of the
herd is just in this dry riverbed behind
the dam wall seeking some shade there we
have a great ale swinging in the knob
form thicket alrighty we're going to go
and find the diminutive characters I
promised we'd try and introduce to you
in the meantime let us go across to the
dried Sydney macaw see and find out what
his plans are for this the thirteenth
episode of Safari lives a very very good
afternoon and welcome to the beginning
of the afternoon Safari my name is
Sydney and I am travelling with Dave and
Holly
we are going to give you the best
experience where I am this afternoon is
where Tandy and Columbus tracks has been
spotted earlier this morning and now I
can pick up some of the warning calls in
the area the chances of seeing Tony and
Kalama they are very high this afternoon
and for your questions and comments you
can follow us on Twitter hashtag safari
live you can also follow us on YouTube
chat stream I can hear some kind of the
alarm calls coming from my left hand
side from this dry riverbed I'm just
gonna go in there and try and see if
there is something at the moment
so those kids must be definitely left
somewhere in this area
so now let's go to the Maasai Mara
Jeremy is doing something is raining
today in Mara we are definitely looking
for some rain in Africa
welcome to the Maasai Mara for the
softer noon Safari lives guess what
we're in the middle of a torrential
downpour I have absolutely no idea where
that came from
it is echoing so loudly off the roof if
you paint her head there are chip you
need to close up those water streaming
in I'm soaked
from trying to get the covers down in
time what I thought was a drizzle has
turned into I'm hoping a relatively
transient downpour and the reason that
I'm hoping that it's a transient
downpour is because at the moment we
can't actually see anything because on
this side of me which is where the rain
seems to be coming from at the moment
was waffles I'm not idea if she's still
there or not she was there she went down
to fetch her Cubs and then the heavens
opened and dumped their contents upon
our heads can only hope that this is a
temporary Masai Mara storm now the
reason that we're here at waffles Den is
twofold one we really want to see her
babies but to more importantly I have
lost the communal den and I cannot work
out exactly what's going on and so far
being at waffles den seems to be the
place to be and it's where the rest of
the clan spend their days
though it would be a stretch to compare
waffles to Goldilocks her natal den site
has become the regular hangout for
members of the bear family the
unconcerned waffles found a resting spot
that was just write a little sloth bear
no longer comparable to a pocket rocket
enjoyed some loving attention from his
older sister teddy bear who seems to be
showing all the signs of maternal
yearnings the oldest bear sister Pola
enjoyed a good back scratch unaware of
impending tragedy securing her dominance
waffles did not let the earth sign
presence stop her from allowing us a
brief view of one tatty eared waffle
--it and basically that's all we get of
waffles as Cubs us just a few brief
glimpses before they disappear
underground and that's why I was hoping
it would be different this afternoon
apparently I was mistaken it doesn't
look like there is a single safe place
to be there I mean the sun is shining on
to us
from the west but because it's now late
in the afternoon it's coming through and
it's it's basically illuminating us
without really helping because it is
still pouring here and at first I
thought I'd just chosen the one bad
place in the Mara to be and I was sort
of having a word with waffles about a
poor choice in Dane site all the painful
thing is as well I've been with waffles
I've just been thinking that this
weather is perfect hyena hunting weather
and she's hungry and so is the rest of
the clan which means there's a really
good chance they're out there somewhere
hunting and the problem is is that
waffles she doesn't need to go with them
hunting she just needs to show up at the
end of it and take what is her right as
the queen of the north clan I'm gonna go
I don't know if we can't move we're
stuck we just have to sit here and hope
that the weather blows over she's on the
side of me and I really don't know if
she's still here or not
so while I wring out my sleeves in
consternation and hits cooker to James
who is at voir tell Adam hopefully in
some better weather we are much better
weather this is deeply irritating we
found this creature that we were hoping
to show to you you got him you got him
okay since all spotted him look like
it's in there I think that's it you've
got it well spotted that everybody is a
baby Lapwing a tiny little baby Lapwing
and it's a blacksmith Lapwing it is
alive we've just seen it move in there
and so that is our latest character will
be watching its progress with great
interest now what I'll do since I let me
drive around the other side maybe we'll
get a bit of view of it just keep an eye
because if it moves it will almost
certainly disappear I'm watching it now
I'm watching I'm watching
get a view of it now so it was born not
long ago yeah I think a few days ago
actually I'm not lost
can you see it stores in yeah I get to
zoom in and I'll guide you and yeah keep
going there go right a bit touch no
there straight in go straight in there
out of it a bit more focus I'm gonna
sick
yeah I know it's there zoom straight in
there middle of little the frame to the
right to the right there that's it there
you got it right a bit now zoom punch
zoom punch it
are you punched you got it you see it we
can see it since all you can't it's
middle of the frame well done it's
middle of the frame there is a little
thing
you got him now isn't that amazing it's
beautifully camouflaged you can hear its
parents
is Catherine those are the parents
making in the noise we're not gonna hang
around here for too long but we are over
the course the next few weeks going to
follow the progress of this delightful
little Lapwing chick in that suite out
of the nest almost immediately on birth
and one of the few kinds of birds that
are born precocial in other words able
to run straight away and like sort of
naked example of say a hornbill or a
lilac breasted roller very nice but I
think we're going to go and have a look
now at some action associated with the
great horse Anna I forget exactly which
piece of action this is curse nadja mind
reminding me my brain is too small
ah yes it is the great feeling and by a
father of son
so you can see there there is well one
hesitates to say this but not a lot of
honor amongst the leopards it comes to
each other and you will see later on
that it is not only chingada that lacks
a certain honor when it comes to his hmm
shall we say visiting dinner rights none
of them are particularly appreciative of
the efforts the others make in order to
kill so that's the story and let's have
one last look of this chap and then
we'll press on I do think it's quite
interesting however that over the last
little while both all four Tandi Columba
or Sanne Anton garner have been around
in the same area and I think it's quite
fascinating that ting garner is not
marking further to the south and there
is another male down there down sort of
operating or little gari which is the
reserve to the south of us and possibly
even onto chitwa and i think that other
male is probably preventing ting ghana
from going down there and perhaps trying
to mate with goo Java who is almost
certainly in heat at the moment so we'll
discuss that a little bit later but it
is quite interesting to see the Dux
dukedom well I mean it's it's bigger
than it's been four months certainly
since the arrival of [ __ ] amore but I'm
not sure how much South he's going at
the moment he certainly pressured from
the north I think he's probably gonna
start expanding further west again
because hoping what he seems to have
absconded almost exclusive
to the west and half of Earth loser and
on to elephant Plains so that's quite
interesting and will be very fascinating
to see what happens
in the near future good okay let's leave
this little left wing poor little thing
and then press on and see if we can find
another cat for us Kim yes it does make
me nervous I was worried about driving
over one of them but I knew that if we
got close the parents would start to
make a huge noise they've definitely
only had one chick here and I was pretty
sure Kim apparently oh dear apparently
they used to have three and now they've
only got one left
but yes Kim I'm being very careful about
where I Drive apparently the baboons ate
one of them nasty baboons they do do
that frequently in fact I would suspect
that one of the major predators of young
Miss Ling's like that when they are so
small and vulnerable
one of the major predators would be
blues we shall leave these Impala press
on and see if we can't give Aubry a hand
finding Tandy and Columba now Jaime of
course is sitting in the rain the
pelting rain which I suppose is probably
apropos of the general mood from the
north clan this week
we are indeed sitting in the rain it is
absolutely pouring at least it's managed
to change directions for a second so
we've managed to move around just a
little bit in the vain hope and I really
do feel that it is a vain hope that
waffles might emerge I don't think she
has any such intentions though because
it is quite frankly a thoroughly
unpleasant day and I wish that I could
send some of this rain across to Juma
because I'm sure that they need it more
than I do
well the price that North plan pays for
the territory that they have and they
really do have prime prime territory oh
I think it's lightning that way I think
we might be okay
the price that they pay for the prime
territory along the river crossings is
everything that comes along with the
river there between the escarpment in
the river and they get this massive
drainage of water along in this
direction what that means is they live
in a swamp our we have no idea exactly
what events for fell north plan and one
particular come in particular a
particular cup in particular however we
do suspect that this weather might
actually have had something to do with
it now what we're about to show you is
not for sensitive viewers because it has
been an extraordinarily sad sad week for
the hyenas of North plan
the Meriweather has an uncanny leaning
towards pathetic fallacy and a gloomy
and damp afternoon heralded tragedy at
the North Klan den
polar bears cub was dead over and again
polar bear tried to call her lifeless
cub out into the open under the watchful
eye of her Queen
the normally stoic waffles seemed at a
loss
gently picking up the carcass and
placing it back in the den repeatedly
with all of the care that a mother might
show a living cub waffles and polar
bears mother Sawa formed a protective
wall against Polar's grief eventually
waffles seemed to realize that the
carcass had no place in the den and
moved it away before bounding back to
bodily block Pola from her own living
cubs driving home the message that there
was nothing for her to search for no cub
that would respond to her call it struck
me in that moment that no other hyena
was allowed near the carcass apart from
the morning mother there is no room for
sentimentality in nature and it was
polar bears right to recover what little
resource she could nature's bitter and
cruel consolation prize
[Music]
polar bear wandered off alone in her
heartache as the Queen stood
protectively over her own two cubs I
guess it seems somewhat appropriate that
we have this weather today I mentioned
it's the researchers and they said it
was because the Mara was crying which I
think was dramatic even even for me I
think that was a little bit too dramatic
so a very sad week for North clan a
relief in a way that waffles as Cubs of
both alive and I'll explain why firstly
because she's old she's over 12 years
old
stop spray weed splashing off the window
she's 12 over 12 years old and waffles
has had a tendency to have boys which
means that there's been no one to pass
the leadership onto except for her
daughter who died under mysterious
circumstances years ago so there really
is entire hope for the leadership of
north plan resting on two little Cubs
shoulders I don't and it's it's the
unfortunate thing that we want you as
humans look for a reason we want to look
for an answer we want to know what
happened
I don't think waffles killed that
cupboard even though she is a high
ranking female she was she has a
reputation as being very benign I've
never seen her overly aggressive and I
don't think she had a reason to doesn't
mean she didn't but that's just my
personal opinion I think perhaps the
combination of the weather and the fact
that polar bear didn't move her cub away
from waffles so she was restricted to
access whenever waffles wasn't here
which might not have been good timing
for that cub oh it's getting lighter I
think that might have been the reason
but the truth is we'll never know
unfortunately poor polar bear hasn't
come back ever since we saw her the next
day
briefly and she's moved off and chances
are that we won't actually see her again
for an extended period of time poor
thing her daughter's been around
daijobu has been around
well I'm sorry that we had to we have to
show you all aspects of their lives not
just a happy moments and that was a very
tragic moment indeed waffles usually
with her good sense of timing would pop
her head up roundabout now as she feels
the rain lessening
Constance King I don't think the Danes
get too flooded I don't know actually
that's not true
I think the dead does get flooded and I
think there would be much better off if
they move just a little bit further that
way to their old Inn
the Cubs are usually I mean these hyenas
raise Cubs under these conditions all
the time the sear is not much worse at
least this time of year is not much
worse than it was last year
I think the Cubs are able to move away
from it but what I think really happened
is where the stain is with the soil type
I think the mud was constantly wet and
sticky and you saw how offices Cubs have
been coming out of the day and they
coated in the stuff and these tiny
little creatures need constant milk and
attention from mom because they're so
small and their metabolisms working
really quickly to try and keep them warm
I get I'm guessing we honestly don't
know and we'll never know but it does
get very muddy and I am hoping I mean if
you look at the entrance I don't know
actually if Archie can see that one of
the entrances there no I can't I'm too
far forward but if you were to see the
entrance and I'll show you once this
rain abates which it seems to be doing
you would see just how mud slicked it
has become already just from this rain
and the road that I drove on which was
dry on my way in is now under water I
don't know if this was their best choice
but I guess as I said they've been doing
this for a long long time
P Hart if the cop was bitten by a snake
which is a possibility you want to know
if if that could poison the mother no
it's the interesting thing about venom
and and poison and the difference
between them
you could most likely I wouldn't advise
that please don't do this but you could
actually ingest an amount of venom if
you didn't have any cuts or injuries in
your mouth for open gaps your stomach
acid would actually dissolve it so it
within if it had been bitten by a snake
and if there was venom still in its body
the mother's eating it she'd still be
okay most likely no I don't snake is not
a bad suggestion it is possible
particularly if it was seeking shelter
from this horrendous weather just seems
uncannily bad luck that it should have
been Polar's cub but then you never know
Awful's it stopped raining now almost
just like that it's over and done
hopefully she'll come out once it passes
properly Oh on a somewhat sad note from
the Maasai Mara and north clan let's go
cheer ourselves up with a Sydney and
some Mayans I am very lucky I just
managed to get hold of one of the
beautiful young male lions I can see
they're all by himself not to show which
correlation is he belonging to is
enjoying some sleep but looking at the
bellies to me it seems like there's
nothing in their berries unless maybe is
the positioning of sleeping
I haven't seen the male lions for quite
a long time here in Juma game reserve
the our vodka coalition the last time I
saw them it was by the first week of my
employment which was early July that has
been long long time ago
I had a great sighting of the in Coahoma
lions at this week and this inhuman ions
they did something very much interesting
as they were trying to corner one of the
oldest leopard in the property ting
Ghana if it was not because of the big
[Music]
[Music]
that was tremendous
those pride have proven to us that the
Lions indeed are the king of the jungle
he of cinching up by the tree turn to
avoid them by all means so if it was not
of the tree I can promise you something
whatever happened that they they want in
Ghana
so I hope this middle iron is gonna wake
up here so that we can see him nicely
about looking at the bones at the back
you can see that it's not that looking
very very full see it's very hungry
maybe this lion today difficult to tell
his conditioner when he's lying down
like that
so this Lions can be able to sleep for
18 hours
Rosalind the Lions are part of those
animals which are not feeding every day
but some of the males who got kicked off
from the prize who are not even part of
this coalition walking by themselves
they do target small animals and if for
instance this kind of a big lion catched
something like a scrub hair is obviously
not going to last in the body it will be
digested very quickly Lions normally
they eat after every 5 to 6 days and
that is determined by hunting activities
it's not like they are going to be
successful on day 6 sometimes it can be
difficult
so now let's see James has got some
zebra zebras are also part of the
animals targeted by these kind of big
predators yes indeed they are and
especially this time of the year because
there are no Buffalo around the moment
necessary this time of year but at this
time because there are no Buffalo around
you know what I mean subtle difference
there so those are some zebras and we
also have some wildebeest with them
there they are I say the word wildebeest
hoping that Tristan is watching it gets
up his nose terribly when we say
wildebeest because of course it's a
Valle de beast because it's a Dutch word
or Afrikaans word and we should say it
as such and I said to him but you know
some people just don't pronounce it like
that and he said well he gave me a
really good example of why it should be
pronounced like that I think it was
something like you don't pronounce
impala i'm pilar do you know you don't
you say impala because that's how the
word was said originally and so I'm
going to just say Phil the best although
I love to say wildebeest there's
something about it that I really enjoy
there is a lovely mixed herd of grazers
here now I think they're probably
hanging around with each other not so
much because they're eating different
parts of the grass plants but because
they are looking out for predators I
think that's what's happening now now
nowhere near the sleeping a vocal male
lion they could however be very near
Tandy and Columba ba you say you love
the stripes yes will the stripes are
really what makes zebras zebras
otherwise I guess there'd be horses
they are very appealing their existence
is still something of a mystery and you
can read books with ridiculous theories
on why they should exist out here
including theories on the stripes
perhaps having some kind of repelling or
repulsive effect on the Flies perhaps
helping to regulate body temperature I
think the only one that holds any water
whatsoever is the theory that they are
there simply to break the outline of the
animal especially in terrain like this
and especially at Twilight and just
after Twilight when Lions their main
predators are on the hunt
you must remember that a lion's eye does
not see in the same detail that ours can
but it does see very good contrast no
sure we don't get black wildebeest Jimmy
don't get black wildebeest in any of the
three and a half million hectares making
up the greater than proper trance
frontier park of which we are a very
small pimple on the far western edge you
get black Valda based in slightly drier
areas and normally up on the high felt
pretty much in similar areas to those
that you might find our only southern
african gazelle and that is the
Springbok so there are no black
wildebeest here at all
although these ones do look blackish
they are the same color as black
wildebeest alrighty well those zebras
looks towards where we are going to try
and find tangental number let's go back
up to the Marcy Mara
where Jaime Patterson doesn't have just
two or three scraggly wildebeest she has
hundreds of thousands I'm back to
talking about Valle de beast and zebra
in the Maasai Mara the rain well
the inconvenient for us is a truly good
thing over this part of the triangle
because what that means is that it's
going to keep the migration here for
longer our North clan and I'm leaving
waffles for now we'll come back a little
bit later
North clan hasn't really had their share
of the migration this year sure they've
had some of the river crossings but
ultimately last year they've all the
beasts were all through this area this
could go very badly there we go driving
through a river last year this whole
place was full of all the beasts this
year they have stayed a little bit
further to the south and for very good
reason however we've been spending time
with them and we would love to tell you
about their movements and one zebra that
stood out from the crowd
a massive portion of the migration
remain in the south of the Mara Triangle
on the fresh green flash of the burnt
areas as well as the lush grazing of the
salt lake the sounds that surround the
massive herds are always something
special that you never quite get used to
that coupled with the sheer numbers is
always spectacular we were extremely
lucky to find a rare leucistic zebra
amongst the herds it is always special
to see something out of the ordinary and
this golden zebra was a real treat to
the north a few scattered herds of zebra
and wildebeest were around the main
crossing points a small herd of 15
individuals decided to brave the Mara
River the crocodiles have had a tough
time this year with very few large
crossings in their horns there wasted no
time heading for the small group of
zebra
their eagerness showing with a few
failed attempts but the need to cross
amongst the zebra was too great
Anna's saurian reinforcements arrived
the fate of one brave zebra was sealed
a battle for the zebra continued at the
behemoths drifted downstream
just to clarify because I realize in
hindsight that might have sounded quite
awful when I said the zebra that stood
out from the crowd I meant the leucistic
one not the one that stood out for the
crowd from the crowd for the crocodiles
that would have been very horrible to
say oh there's the migration we think of
it as these terribly tragic crossings
and yes it is phenomenally sad to
witness a zebra like that being caught
by a crocodile through no fault of its
own was just the wrong zebra in the
wrong place in the queue coming through
the river but actually what we should
celebrate as well is the sheer numbers
of animals that make this journey safely
each and every year it is a really small
majority mainly really small minority
that do not make it through the Mara
River the toe peas are included in the
migration as well that antelope in front
of the zebra and a lot of them are
heavily heavily pregnant funny you
should ask that because we've got some
we we have some tales of some
cantankerous herbivores to tell you a
little bit later in the afternoon but
yes sometimes herbivores do fight with
other herbivores aha that's what I was
looking for as topi are looking at it -
there's a hyena of North Clan stalking
through the muddy area waiting for the
opportunity to hunt we'll go that way in
a bit but first time has answered Bob's
question Rhino Buffalo elephant are
usually the one that chase other
herbivores around there for some reason
don't like to share their personal space
and they often do particularly Buffalo
Bulls but all of the larger herbivores
and hippo hippo will actually do it and
in fact sometimes during the migration
hippopotamus will actually step in and
kill a poor unsuspecting zebra
wildebeest simply because it has come
too close to them in their water usually
that happens when there's not much space
when there's lots of competition in the
water and the hippos are stressed
and their tempers pushed a breaking
point but yes herbivores can be
aggressive towards other herbivores you
get random instances where something
like a topi will chase that Thomson's
gazelle for no apparent reason okay I'm
gonna go I'll catch up with us hyena
that's up ahead because I want to see
what they get up to we know they like
the sweater but also cuz I still haven't
found the communal den Angela it's an
interesting thing with the migration and
obviously it varies from year to year
you're looking at around about a
duration of four months but it can be
longer it can be shorter so sometimes
it's five months and really good
conditions and it really is entirely
dependent upon the rain there we go
that's exactly what I was expecting
I can't turned around and stuck and
stuck I'm stuck I can't turn around Cal
get us to the hane and then I'll turn
around so this year is expected to be
short because there was so much rain
earlier on in the year
whereas the year before was a much
longer longer year our for predators in
certain places wet conditions like this
hello you
looks like waffles our son Ferg
predators like this conditions like this
are wonderful but for Lili predators of
South Africa usually the dry season is
their time of Plenty look at that this
lion is still very much ice next not
showing any other activities and you can
see the the mane is starting to grow is
getting very big this kind of Maine twin
is too hot during the hot weathers like
this they do give them a problem when it
comes to the weather so they get very
hot inside there you can see it's like a
very big blanket
so this Mane helps them in order to
impress the females from the prize and
also during the territorial challenges
fighting they help to protect the neck
yes good that the Lions the gap between
the head and the body is too small they
don't have a long neck which is out
there cause imagine these animals they
find to they fight too much and if they
they were having something like a long
neck it was going to be a challenge all
the time you can see that that ear is
very hairy
a sky I am not too sure that is
something I am asking myself because
when I'm looking at this issue they the
bones at the back the heat bones I can
see that he is not looking very healthy
look at that so I think this is kind
it's not a poor condition but it's a
fair condition so when considering the
method called the bone marrow index the
method used in order to determine the
health status of an animal I can say
this one is on fair condition so maybe
he's gonna wake up while I'm here and
then I would be able to see what is it
killing giving him a problem
but when I got here he was not sleeping
he was just very relaxed the head was up
so I couldn't even notice that he's
having some challenges look at that
these kind of animals they've got to
learn a lot because yearning helps them
to cool the brain temperature you can
see now is is up AC maybe he had me yet
that I was very worried that we want to
see him with the head up maybe he picked
up something you know these animals can
be very much inquisitive and the its
ability works nicely also when they're
sleepy so now let's go to Jamie who's
got the hyenas hunting look now is is
moving I was right this is the weather
for hunting hyenas and Ferguson Farms
son of the matriarch is at it now this
is basically how hyenas hunt in this
weather he's going to run backwards and
forwards and backwards and forwards and
he might lose interest or he might not
but essentially what he's hoping is that
one of the antelope or the zebra is
going to panic slip and fall he's
looking around because some backup would
be very useful in this whole process now
he's dashing off that way he's taking us
into essentially a swamp so I don't know
how far we can follow him but I've been
dying to show you the hunting technique
live because chances are he's not gonna
be successful but you just never know
and neither does he and already he's
causing panic he's getting zebra to run
away from him we are so gonna get stuck
but not today not today
oh that was a mistake
already he's our paste me so you can
understand what it's like trying to find
and follow not fine follow a hyena
I mean it's hunting I don't want to look
at the wards under my wheels I'm not
looking I'm not looking I'm not looking
where's he gone I've lost him straighten
your head dead ahead theory has got him
all done thank you onto the road this
way
around the very large hole that would
take us swimming which is not something
we want to do focus maybe run oh we're
going this way and we are off running
once again now imagine trying to do this
at night in the dark obviously because
it's night and you get an idea of what
we've been up to for the last four
months
he is outpacing me I'm going it okay I'm
going at 30 kilometers an hour because
it's weight he is way ahead of me
and he's stopping to look at me now and
again there we go
here he is I'll stop to you in a second
I'm sorry zebra if you're not careful
I'm gonna spray you I'm going to give
you a shower
Milica if you were to take me at my word
from the final episode of the gauntlet I
would have told you that the hyenas
top speed is around about 50 miles an
hour
now that was because I got my kilometers
and my miles mixed up
that is not true they cannot run oh look
what you found yourself the victim of
the migration probably an old hyena meal
actually with where it is the actual top
speed of a hyena is around about 60
kilometers an hour possibly 70 if they
really gunning it so they don't rely on
speed in the same way a cheetah my to do
or even a lion but essentially they just
rely on an animal making a mistake life
is tough for all creatures out here
apparently a sydney's lion is not
looking in the best of conditions look
at that now that flagon is showing some
activities now we can see that he is
heading towards the northern side not to
show if maybe others are in front or he
has been left here a couple of hours or
they have splitted few days ago so I'm
just gonna
now again carry on forward and see if we
can have a better society
maybe is gonna lead us to something
I have noticed that he is limping I'm
not too sure if he's limping from the
fight or he is limping because he has
been sleeping there from one side all
day long
yeah now he's working much better
Paul cat mama the Lions can travel very
long distances especially the
territorial males the male's they walk
much more long distances than the
females because they've got a
responsibility of patrolling their
territories so I'm not too sure in terms
of the kilometres but lions they are
active a lot for about two to four hours
at night they spend much of their time
sleeping look at that now we've got a
good sighting here from where I am you
can see that he picked up some noise
there was a daycare I just saw it occur
from this drainage line going up maybe
that is what he picked up now now
I'm not going to give up I'm going to
keep following until I see his
intentions it's very rare for the Lions
to wake up by this time of the day and
start showing some activities mostly the
Lions they sleep and wake up just by the
sunset
so now let's go back to Jim so is
driving and here his plans
but my plan is to first of all show you
that Impala over there there's an
apologist over there a male Impala and
that poor fellow
unfortunately lost a cousin possibly an
aunt maybe even a sister earlier this
week
two wild dogs the wild dogs then had
their kill another so but Grimm there I
mean showed you a few grim things today
so far and further a couple of grim
things further to come but very
interesting nonetheless and I think that
that was probably killed by a one wild
dog I don't believe that tündi would
have taken on more than that especially
as it was too heavy for to grab and
quickly take up a tree so I think you'll
probably find that maybe one wild dog
killed it had a little bit to eat and
then either left at all she lipped in
and chased it off so fascinating there
and you can see that well the young
Columba learning her mother's pilfering
ways all is at peace now amongst the
Impala males you can see that they are
not shouting at each other they're not
going oh oh that's what they do of
course in May and that is because the
rut is over but what is very interesting
as we go into spring
is that this very little-known second
read mating season is about to happen
and it is the only time that I have ever
seen Impala actually mating and normally
during the main May mating it happens at
night this will sometimes happen during
the day and so over the course of the
next month make sure to make a stop at
every Impala herd and see if there isn't
any impart of mating going on it's very
interesting and remember these babies
will be born in February just a very
small cohort personating stuff as we go
into the spring rule stick to tried to
attack us let me run it down that's what
it deserves I'm being facetious
everybody under really believe this to
deserve that it's just what happened but
here's the main body of the which is
very nice we're still trying to find
some tracks of tan D'Andra lumber we
haven't managed to have any luck we will
continue research in the meantime back
to the Highness of the Maasai Mara with
Jaime and quite astonish me they have
not enough to eat yet we are still with
our hyena who is a finishing off of
unfortunate member of the migration I
think it looks like a Valda beast but I
honestly am NOT a hundred percent
certain I also said it was Ferb with
great confidence
off in the distance unfortunately we're
about to get hit by the second wave of
the storm on its way towards us I know
where that line is I'll try and see if I
can get there although I don't think we
will what have you got I said it was
Ferg but he's also soaking wet and
fluffed up I'm not a hundred percent
sure of course this is where hyenas come
in extraordinarily useful in an
ecosystem such as this particularly
during the migration Lions have a
tendency to kill and leave especially
when they are full they'll often go on
something like a killing spree or
something akin to a killing spree at
night and then abandon the carcasses and
hyenas are usually the cleanup crew
they'll come through along with the
vultures of course and they will finish
off what they can they're still hunting
during the migration but you'll probably
find that they are hunting less then and
they might otherwise in this particular
time of year they can let the Lions do
the hard work for them speaking of lions
let's go across to Sydney before his
lion vanishes across a boundary so that
I own is slowly now approaching me just
from the very big house of the small
insects that he might mound he is slowly
approaching I saw that he's coming they
see look at that this is beautiful you
can see now he's not limping anymore
maybe that was just because of the long
slip look at that this is very beautiful
with the reflection of the light some
just short of it was they evoke us has
been roaring last week I have heared
them I suspected that is them while I
was watching the rumors at night look at
that
so I'm just gonna try and reverse it so
that we can keep following these big big
big mainline
you can see that is now heading towards
you can see that he is now heading
towards the boundary look at that so
this is beautiful you can see the tip of
the tail is nice nice bushy and black
he's just about to cross now
there's some other stations vehicles
coming to join me
Aroo and this this lion is still part of
the volca coalition not part of the
pride males big bears they start and
young males to form their own group
called a correlation so they are not
every time with the price they only
engage with the females during the
oestrus of the females
so now that lion is disappearing towards
the private property it's marking not
too sure if this is his territory el
this territory belongs to someone him
trying to claim the territory so now
let's go to the Maasai Mara
let's go to Jamie who is called the
lovely hyena interesting Highness of the
Mara guess who showed up to the party we
not actually despite the speed at which
we drove that far away from waffles is
natal then she's come to investigate
what her son is up to and I'm pretty
certain it's her son just watching the
way that they've been interacting around
this pile of all the bones waffles is
hungry she's been at the den she really
has been a phenomenally dedicated mother
she must spend 20 odd hours possibly
even more with those tiny Cubs or at
least in close proximity to them keeping
them safe protecting them from harm in
as much as she can
but even she as a fantastic mother has
to leave the den at some point because
she's got to eat and she's got to keep
herself nourished she's lucky though in
that as the highest ranked member of
North clan she can pretty much shoulder
charge her way into every meal and get
the best of it even if she didn't
participate in the whole process of
catching it now while waffles have may
be able to push around members of her
own clan there are some animals out
there that not even waffles is able to
dominate
the heininger of North Klan were nervous
on the first day of spring and for good
reason
faced with the approach of the largest
land mammal in the world most scattered
but waffles made the conscious decision
to stay with her cubs it was clear from
the outset but the bull did not take
kindly to her presence and there was
little she could do except hide in the
entrance to the den and keep as quiet as
possible it seems odd to think of an
elephant as a threat to a hyena but they
do not appreciate the presence of smelly
carnivores and waffles was trapped in
her hole as the massive mammals moved
over the den content to feed while
risking the structural integrity of the
Cubs home below the surface
we held our breath as the elephant came
within a foot of turning waffles into a
pancake the departure of the elephants
did not mean respite for waffles as next
to pass by was a herd of male buffalo
buffalo are known to be almost
irrationally cantankerous and once again
the dignified Queen was forced to hide
in a somewhat undignified manner perhaps
it was my imagination but when waffles
finally emerged and the threat had
passed she looked decidedly disgruntled
with life before quite literally going
to ground for the rest of the day well
just personally I happen to find waffles
quite expressive as hyenas go but that
might of course entirely be a product of
my anthropomorphizing her and the rest
of her plan they are going to hunt they
are wandering off in the direction of a
zebra she's just called well we were
showing you at the encounter with the
elephants and the Buffalo calling the
rest of her clan to her side and they
have no choice but to answer her call is
built into their instinct so they're
going to be coming unfortunately they
although the rest of the clan is
arriving so is the storm off to the west
of us know that's the east off to the
east of us and I need to go I can't stay
with her because the road is already a
river once the second lot hits I'm gonna
have to run say my name boy interesting
say my name boy it would like to know
who the female such as waffles that mate
with they will mate with the immigrant
males males that have dispersed and
moved in from another clan which is what
most hyenas especially in this area will
do at around about three or so years old
once they reach sexual maturity and what
waffles the son Fergus will be doing
very soon when a male does that he falls
to the bottom of the clan hierarchy
however some males don't migrate or
emigrate
that's the wrong word sorry I've got
migration on the brain now don't
emigrate they move on to different clans
I mean they stay in the same clan and
they will not really be allowed to mate
with their mothers or sisters
but they will mate with other females
that are unrelated waffles is vanishing
off and disappearing we have to run from
the rain we really do so while we do
that to go and entertain yourself with a
very brightly colored bird here's a very
black bird that I haven't put on camera
for a very long time I'm not sure why
other than to say I've done it so many
times before but so we go into the
summer months of course we are going to
be concentrating a lot on birds this is
not a migratory bird of course it is a
at a residential bird and it is of
course the lilac breasted roller we did
find tracks of tandy though the same
tracks I think that they found earlier
today and so the mystery as to where she
is right now continues - well confound
us frankly we'll keep on trying as we
look at this gorgeous bird see if there
aren't perhaps of a long holes somewhere
along the way let's see this bird is
scandalized by something
perhaps it will see tündi coming out of
the drainage line in front of us the
last tracks went into that dry riverbed
to the side there we're just gonna ease
down here
on to a game path let's see what we can
see and everyone is just saying the
beautiful bird it is a beautiful bird
let's just have a quick look up in that
tree there sends off you don't mind do
you see the big tree there it's the big
one
that's it it's called a large fruit
falls thorn
it's called large fruit because it has
everyone together large fruit well done
and it's called a false thorn because it
looks like it might have and thorns
that's well done and you will find that
it doesn't in fact have thorns it is an
L busier tree I think some of the most
beautiful trees we have here are elbers
ears they look they take on the
wonderful shape of the acacia x' without
having the nastiness of their forms so
that is albezia for bzi
the large fruited the full thorn is it
not a magical tree it is not a character
in Safari lives I suppose it could be a
character or part of a character story
if there was a leopard lying in its
boughs but in the absence of an actual
character to show you I am showing you
albezia for bzi where perhaps tandy
might like to stash a kill I'm sure
you're all thoroughly and utterly
astounded by what I've just told you
ah now just to the east of where I now
sit lies a river bed the riverbed of the
great Imam Artie in which there are many
tambuti groves the perfect conditions
for afternoon hunting
so that was quite an amusing thing and
what we didn't show you there because
obviously there's been quite a lot of
gore already and there still is more to
come
is that husana was astonishingly
skillful at dissecting that squirrel so
basically what he did was he used his
incisors to open up the front of the
squirrel and take out the guts he didn't
use his paws at all he just managed to
use gravity and his sharp teeth let's
just peer down into the riverbed there
that's where the tracks have gone and he
managed to extract the elementary canal
drop it on the floor and then that was
it now apparently we're not going to
talk about viscera any further we're
going to go across to some cute baby
elephants I'm very lucky with elephants
a very small head with the little ones
these little ones were playing here now
they are quiet so play is part of the
ways animals learn some of the adaptive
behaviors all day long elephants they
feet are not very far away from the
buffers hooked em I'm sure maybe they
are from there now you can see they are
voiding the Sun as I indicated this
morning that now when the Sun is
on the western side during the sunset
they must look east during the sunrise
they must look west so these animals
they help the vegetation a lot because
when the elephants are defecating every
time is when they are creating the
manure for the vegetation to grow
Rozlyn the elephant's skin is very much
thick not to show in terms of the
centimetres but this is rarely I don't
think the mosquito can even manage to
buy the elephants they might not feel
anything and it does here we have quite
a lot of s you can't see this has
between you're very nice and close you
can see that this body does have a
little bit of us can see they're all
looking very dirty which is normal
elephants they did afire themselves and
they also go for swimming they like to
play in water especially during the the
dry season when it's too hot during
summer season even during lightining
elephants you will see them playing in
water when it's raining they get very
excited with the rain
so the elephants can leave 65 years and
what caused them to die mostly is soon
as they start losing the teeth is when
is going to be very difficult for them
to chew and once they cannot chew this
kind of a very big Paula size 5000
kilograms it needs quite a lot of energy
now that they are feeding on very dry
grass and they pick up the roots and get
all the nutrients they must have to go
very often to the water holes in order
to drink
because the food is dry at the moment so
that Frank is is one of the very
powerful weapon they use the trunk in
order to get the food and they use the
trunk again in order to smell sometimes
you will see them just raising the trunk
trying to get the information from the
particles arena if you can look there
you can see that there's some little bit
of white I think that is because of of
the deity from the eyes or else may be
might find that is something can't see
very very well what it is there but
they've got to clean the eyes every time
you can see there's even some who has
their covering the the eyes protecting
the eyes from the dust it's just like us
and we sleep in the morning we do get
those kind of white stuff coming from
the eyes they also sleep elephants
during the daytime sometimes but not
very often it's very rare to find them
sleeping but if sometimes they sleep
under these big trees and also on top
lifting their head against the termite
man I've seen that you can see the
little one now is going very fast
looking for the other one he's two or
three small ones here so I'm just gonna
now try to reallocate the better spot
for the sighting and
see if we can see them nicely
these elephants are also not very far
away from the border they might
disappear now
sound of the universe the elephants they
are not selective they adjust volka
crazes when they they are just a bulk
feeders they feed on both grass as well
as they the trees and when it comes to
trees they are not selective they do eat
quite a lot of different fruit trees
fruit trees that are eaten by the bears
elephants they also eat them is just
that the Marla fruit is famous and
mostly associated with the elephants but
they also do it other fruits as well
sometimes they even get attracted by
some of the fruits we we carry from the
cars fruit such as watermelons and other
fruits such as oranges attract them a
lot so now let's go to James who is
searching for the leopard maybe you will
be lucky with the lepers
well maybe he will or maybe he'll just
show you a die car or to stop running
stop running stop now gone
ah what a fantastic sighting that
amazing just gorgeous stuff
no luck everybody you may be able to
tell that from the slightly downhearted
way in which I'm speaking
since all let's do that dove hello
little dove humbled as you are it's nice
to see you though can you see the dove
it's the one falling on the ground there
there we are middle of fetcher yeah we
go well done okay turtle dove oh and the
sound the bearded woodpecker I was
rather hoping that around this water
hole would be Hoth Hana Morton Garmin
lace intellect the humbled of eating its
seeds possibly the odd end yes the Sun
is eventually starting to sink on the
second of spring 2018
oh and descends over spotted a bird that
looks like and I think it's just the
wind
I thought flavors have been mangled by
something but no it hasn't it's just the
wind mangling it slightly I used to look
like there when I like that for my head
hair this is a pumped pan in case you're
wondering and it's just a central point
during the dry season this isn't a towel
spur file we're looking at that's pink
legs pinkish beak
and it's too is quite careful about how
it drinks looking out for predators have
you've spotted another one sins or
you're on fire this afternoon
another natal spur file to natal spur
files and one dove whoo-wee and I'm just
sitting here wondering if perhaps if it
doesn't get a pitch up because I'm
pretty sure that at some stage of one
might it's been a hot day
superb two-shot of two birds well done
since all your on fire as I said now if
your fire could extend a spotted cat
that would be fantastic
right as I said at the very first time I
saw you and we showed you the clip of
husana learning from his father how to
steal so he did follow up no let me
start that again so he did apply those
lessons and this week we returned to
China in Columbia at the pulpit rock is
later that day as we arrived in from
tandy dragon kill to India by marilla
sheer power and grace the 12 year old
female showed all our experiences wasted
be killed she then positioned had saved
the arts of the reaches of marauding
scavengers that was sure to come as
darkness fell
was not over softer side gave way as
they intensified no tail pitched in the
tree with the composition now when we
watch that clip in the final control
before we came out on Drive there was a
ripple of laughter that fluttered
through the room at the sight of asanas
smug looking face as he sat in the tree
there and I don't know why it is but he
really does have a bit of kind of
showman clown ship about him if you like
it was just very funny to watch him
sitting there not quite gormless lee but
one cannot feel any resentment for him
stealing the killer from his sister it
just seems to be what he does and then
he looked there clownish lee into the
blue that was very amusing to watch here
are some more impalas let's have a look
at them see if they are getting Emrys
with each other
no they're just going to run away now
husana of course is stealing so is Tandy
and so is Kangana and that is entirely
normal that is what all of the Predators
out here will do if they can the notable
exception of course is the wild dog
which will almost universally not
scavenge if they can avoid it they will
kill their own fresh meat unless
something is very fresh and dead in
front of them then they might try and
eat that cheetahs likewise unlikely to
scavenge just simply because they are
not built for it they try and avoid
other predators and so if there is
happens to be a predator on the piece of
meat you can be sure that a cheetah will
just avoid it rather than trying to
steal that piece of meat but the rest of
them scavenge away at will
well giraffe goal that would seem to be
a correct what should we say correct
lost me words a correct a correct
statement if you like that a family that
thieves together stays together yes oh
so they do that fence is via terror camp
by the way just in case you're wondering
and hisana
aunt and the aunt in Ghana and Columbus
been to put a timer on there off Layton
so that's why we're just sort of driving
the perimeter towards the pan again much
very happily Sydney has managed to find
some large game the same one that we
found earlier today first time in bitter
light a very much interesting to see
that the little one doesn't know how to
use the trunk is trying to grab some of
the small plants and their strengths are
not there and instead is going down just
break it from them inner parts of the
mouth he's battling to break these small
plants from the from the trees so these
little ones they are born while these
mothers are standing so the little one
has to heat the ground as a wake-up call
in order to external life that must be
painful them in the giraffe they are
very popular when it comes to that so
little ones they got to eat droppings of
their mothers when they are still very
new the twins has been recorded in some
of the areas I have seen that but I
haven't experienced it I have never seen
it by myself happening but I have seen
that lot of sources indicating that yes
rarely they do have twins so this babies
when they are still young they have got
to eat droppings of their mothers in
order to get the digestive bacteria
they are born free of all bacterias to
get the bacterias they must do a cup of
physic behavior they must come and eat
droppings of the old ones in order to
get some digestive bacteria otherwise
they are going to battle in the
stomach's forget that trying again to
use a trunk gosh the elephants and
rhinos they do fight I used to work in
one of the private reserves in water bag
before I went to the South African
national parks and there the elephants
they managed to kill a rhino what was
the problem is that elephants were
introduced without the big males to
channel the teenagers in order to behave
so elephants instead of treating the
Rhino they killed the Rhinos they were
trying to mate with the Rhinos by fire
by force and that is how they killed the
Rhinos until the big male was introduced
which then helped in order to calm these
young stars
so this this elephants en Juma not that
very destructive elephants can be very
destructive especially now during the
dry season when food availability is
very much scarce but here is very
difficult to notice that they are
elephants lots of elephants in the
property sometimes elephants when having
the little ones they just uproot trees
they push trees down just to give their
little ones and accessibility to their
food and they want food they won't eat
and finish that tree they will eat and
leave it and move on to the next tree
that is why in the bush year some of the
trees you can see that they adjust to
regenerate the branches from the effects
done by these elephants as they are
trying to regrow again while the
branches are lying on the ground they
are not standing straight you can see
the old ones knows very well how to use
the trunk and see that now is using the
trunk in order to pull that and if its
difficulties I have to break it and get
the inner bark
the little one also managed to pick up
something from the trunk I'm sure the
little one is only now that is starting
to learn how to use this trunk
Constance King looking at the size of
that baby I am sure is the baby which is
now approximately two to three years
it's not that very old I can see that
this baby is still very small his babies
when they are born they are born
weighing hundred and twenty kilograms
that is a lot so animals such as the
elephants and giraffes and these zebras
when they're born must check if the
giraffes and the Zebras already they've
got wolves and elephants as well their
food structure is strong already
for the little one to run in less than
an hour the little one is going to be
able to run because these animals are
very much vulnerable so but the
elephants is not easy for the Predators
to attack their babies because they can
be very much protective sometimes when
threatened the big ones will surround
all the little ones and have them in the
middle accessibility will never be easy
terrific and checks in the droppings of
the elephants you will see that the the
vegetation material is not finally
digested what they are eating now some
of these things are still gonna come out
as they are I developed the elephants
they do drink a lot of water every day
these animals mostly they go to the
water holes twice a day sometimes even
more than that depending on the seasons
and the type of food they are feeding on
they can drink 150 to 200 liters of
water a day so that is a lot but little
ones they've got to drink the milk from
their mothers but also when you when
they go to the water towels when they're
still young
not able to use the trunks you will see
the big ones collecting the water from
the trunk and try to give them
so now let's go back to James who is on
a search for the leopard maybe he's got
some fresh tracks they're not to show
how successful he is a very unsuccessful
we're going down now towards some water
towards twin dams and we'll work our way
back up from there there's no reason to
do that other than it's been hot and
there's water there there were two other
leopards found down to the south
yesterday evening so maybe we'll be
lucky it's a glorious afternoon oh dear
here we have a small traffic jam
happening watch this everybody
I'm now going to do something very
amusing
good afternoon now while that is a
relative relatively amusing and the
point the point of it is that I then
don't have to say hello you see we can
just keep going on our search other than
having an awkward conversation where we
say hello hello
do not talk now can we carry on please
oh sorry about that you know too much oh
dear I can't believe it Herbert Herbert
has just found a leopard where we were
sorry Herbie I missed that I've just
been past Gallagher pen what have you
got there
I don't believe it copy I'd like to make
my way if I can Herbert is managed to
find horse Anna where we were looking
this does not surprise me greatly
because Herbert is a genius apparently
he can't see him very well so we will
slowly wind our way up there and we'll
see if we get lucky I think he went for
a little walk around the pan around
about where we were looking at those
around those birds
anyway
we'll see what we can do remarkable man
that absolutely remarkable
otherwise and things have not been
massively successful I see that Andrew
did not come from condemn so that's
where we will continue to go Jenna
yes Murphy's Law and her be skill is
basically what happened there I'm not
sure that it was too much of Murphy
probably much more of her be and not
enough skill brought to bear by myself
okay miss Ana you say I need glasses I
yes quite possibly I actually don't have
short sight and but maybe some glasses
would help don't be quite useful if I
could have some leopard spotting glasses
that was slightly embarrassing then that
happens of course I didn't have to
confess it to you which I probably
shouldn't have
but we're at the waterhole now what is
there any of our characters for Safari
lives
[Music]
now just add ICO which is now almost
certainly going to run away yes
there it goes running away
oh no caught in no man's land now what
do you do
aren't you gonna do eat a jackal berry
fruit
thank you sins Oh for your leveling
skills the Sun has now set that sort of
dusk breeze has begun to blow and as the
duiker makes its way out of frame I
think we're going to make our way back
towards where herberto has found horse
armor fine looking dark Aram yes you
thought you heard me say that didn't you
mm-hmm often see them this confidingly I
think he thinks we can't see him
there are a lot of these things around
and you don't realize how many until you
drive around here in the dead of night
flashing your spotlight from side to
side because then you realize that there
are hundreds and hundreds of darker
around this area
yes they do our Lorimar I know exactly
what you mean about them having funny
faces they've got sort of around Roman
ish type nose I guess and well they
don't smile very much just makes them
look a little odd
there is nothing drinking here let us
head straight for of the pan
we're husana was in the meantime Sydney
is also still driving and searching
MIT's go across to him
I am now heading towards the twins an
area just to see if maybe we can find a
leopard or something in that area so but
now Here I am I've got a very beautiful
spot I am right on a very beautiful spot
for the sunset in Africa look at that
this is lovely
every time I come here by this time of
the day I always enjoy this kind of
sight in the sunset sunset is something
people don't take into consideration but
here in Africa I can promise you sunset
will never get old every time is looking
new so when the Sun is going down like
this the other insects such as the
termites after the first rains they can
be able to pick up the temperature
fluctuations when the temperature is
going is now cooling it's when they know
that this is the best time to release
the reproductives to go are for breeding
purposes but also the animals if you can
check animals as well now is when they
are going to wake up but those kind of
insects such as the termites in there
the activities are not determined by day
and darkness light and darkness doesn't
work there's always dark they feel what
is happening outside in order to release
them they don't depend on the light from
the Sun bigger animals for them to do
their activities now that the Sun is
going down some is when they can see
that now is getting dark and they starts
to come out and perform their nocturnal
life look at that the Sun going behind
the drunkard drunk as big mountains
that is what I'm seeing from the naked
eyes without any sunscreen lovely
tears from a dream here is certainly the
same like me son said to me is always
very very interesting so now I am going
to go down to us the wisdom area and see
if I can find something interesting
maybe I will see a leopard a missing
tiny and telomere not too sure if James
is winning on that side so now let's go
to James he's winning one is going
towards a leopard we're on our way at
high speed up towards the Gallagher pan
with with any luck we will still have a
view of husana who I think he's having a
drink at the moment
like I say The Sun has set certain
lovely evening always this time the year
after the hot days now husana in one of
the most gory moments of the week
managed to catch himself a little baby
dykey
was his method of eating but really he
made us a little little green a young
guy : was the practical cheats victim he
was already full so he allows some
acrobatics to whet the appetite and the
task of shoving
now that tip didn't quite show the full
extent of what he was doing there
it took him I would say a good three
minutes or so to suck push if you like
all of the bolus through the stomach
lining and then it kind of made a
disgusting squelching noise and fell
onto the floor which we didn't think
would be appropriate to show you we all
felt very ill afterwards but you can see
that he does certainly have some
interesting tastes but that no cat is
prepared to eat the muck that comes out
of their preys stomach fair enough
I wouldn't either but they certainly are
fans of haggis which is basically what
they ate there it's gonna quickly talk
to Herbert maybe I'm on quarantine
no nothing let's just keep going along
here
we're not far now now since then horse
Anna seems to have come down into this
area well obviously he has he's just
near the gala go pan and he hasn't moved
from yeah I saw him twice on foot in the
drainage line just to this sort of well
I guess you could say north of our camp
next to the Gallagher pan and for about
three nights now he's just kind of spend
his time around they're not showing any
signs of territoriality at all
staying low not killing Teresa I'm
afraid I didn't hear that wish and all I
got was why don't we get Christmas fangs
here I don't think that's what you asked
why don't they eat oh they do eat the
intestines that's what he was eating he
was eating the intestines but he was
pushing out the half-digested bolus so
the bonus is the kind of masticated
grass and crushed-up grass that
eventually passes into the intestines
and what he was doing there is sucking
me intestine the intestine is going down
his throat and then the bonus was coming
out they didn't want to eat that now
absolutely eat intestine not always but
they do they like it I mean like is
probably a strong word
I'm just gonna get all of her bit again
maybe what's my best approach from our
camp he's still at the pan
got me thank you you're not too far from
there as the crow flies but it always
strikes me that this next road takes an
inordinate amount of time to get along
as it wines
I do feel that we should show you at
least one character from our safari
lives showed during the course of the
next few minutes we haven't managed to
find one from Juma
tamo I'm sure he's physically capable of
sawing he certainly hasn't sword yet as
far as we know but he would only saw if
he was trying to be territorial when she
isn't yet he's not really old enough for
that interestingly Michael fleet or do
you might knows of a avid viewer and
follower of our animals will over the
place Nev found some record of what he
is fairly sure is hook amore as a cub
looked to me around about ten or eleven
months old in when was it was 2014 2013
which would put oak amore this young
male leopard not at six years old but it
may be just five now how that relates to
this story of course is that husana is
approaching where he's not nearly three
yet but he he's turned off and you know
I still think he's got at least eighteen
months at least eighteen months before
he would start behaving in a territorial
fashion I must having be quite nice if
he stayed around here ting gana had
another 18 months of glory and then kind
of retired Institute and that would be
very nice of Hassan I just took over
from him there is the magical prince
himself sitting on top of the termite
mound marvelous marvelous stuff courtesy
of the great H causa
all of you know the great H causa of
course because he is the man who walks
with us when he's guiding this afternoon
I mean just pull a little turn around
this way a couple of sticks in the way
income
so everybody I'm making a hash of this
all right
make an utter hash you laugh at me again
since I'm going to be forced to remove
you from the cart by means of a buffalo
thorn there you are
he is I always didn't get the impression
that's young Mehsana is pretending to be
regal and he feels every so often after
behaving like a clown that he should
pretend to be regal that's what he's
doing now prodcut my well I do to a
certain extent and I think that all
these cats get a little bored from time
to time especially as youngsters and
because they're so young and because he
doesn't have siblings anymore well you
wouldn't really be with a sibling of
this edge anyway but yes I do think that
he does to a certain extent get bored
now the reason that you're not seeing
Jamie at the moment is not because she
finds any of you offensive it is because
she has been savaged by Lightning Welton
she hasn't actually she's avoiding being
savaged by lightning that is lovely
picture of the young prince to take my
camera out and take a picture of the
guests on the other vehicles as they
were taking a picture of us
Bob well you're a new viewer and you say
what is sowing when it pertains to
animals you've only heard it used
pertaining to constructional carpentry
well that's pretty logical the answer is
that it's the sound that leopards make
that sounds like a saw cutting through
wood goes a little bit like this that's
basically what it sounds like and he is
not sawing yet because he's not a
territorial male he's just lurking in
his dad's territory at the moment and we
are so grateful for his lurking in his
dad's territory we see him almost on a
daily basis and thoroughly enjoy his
antics
yes our Laura Moore his paw pads are
very special I don't know why they're
special I couldn't tell you what it is
about them that makes me feel I will
agree with you that they are special but
they most certainly are very special paw
pads indeed as this is tail Wow his
whole makeup really fantastic it
so he's been sleeping very close to here
while I was bemoaning the Cape
Turtledove and the two hotels per files
at sins ordered his best to create an
entertaining segment from and well he
was not far from here
and then he decided that he needed to
come and have a drink that's what he did
and now he's lying on his termite mound
attempting to be regal so tempting
simply because he does have such a
clownish nature
Eureka heads up he's listening to the
call of the Scots owl he's clearly a
male leopard who likes a bit of birding
a bit of Ornithology
Rosie lo here we sit with us Anna
Sydney's attention I'll have to search
for other cancers see what he comes up
with I am now heading towards the tree
house damn has to go and see if maybe
I'll be lucky with Sandy and Kalama as
the last track of these two hares they
go disturb here somewhere in that area
and these cats they are depending on
this water holes if now Hasan is by de
pan maybe tandy and talam Barda pending
here by the tree ostium unless they are
also going to the same place because
this week there has been quite a lot of
interaction of this case all together by
the jam cam so I'm not sure if maybe
these two will also go there in order to
join a Hosanna no alarm call nothing is
very much quiet at the moment so I just
want to quickly rush there and see if
maybe there is something I have been
there twice already
I've been day in the morning and then
I've been there again just before I
started but I didn't see anything
so Tandy and Columba they are playing
some hide-and-seek
but sometimes let's go back to asana
maybe I'll find something when I get
there maybe he'll find something Lewis
maybe he'll find that scoffs ow
he is talking about but maybe he worked
I think he's not particularly hungry he
hasn't had a Sunday roast yet but I
don't think that he's I think that he's
after anything right now
Angelina yes absolutely termites would
bite him on his bottom if he lay upon an
open chimney where there were soldiers
guarding the entrance they would most
certainly bite him on his bottom and
he'd be he'd get oh like that's your
team get and then you'd probably move
from where he is now but there are no
termites currently building chimneys on
the smile' this mound may in fact be
dormant there may not be any termites in
it at all but he'd be careful of
climbing any mound that had opened
chimneys because he will know that their
bite
now DG photography as he looks over the
top of our heads I wonder - perhaps if
his father is not approaching from the
other side this is going to be very
interesting
DG photography he will most likely
retain that think nose yes he's staring
completely fixedly over there look at
him it wasn't that kind of careless
looking that he was doing towards the
scoffs owl now he's been concentrating
completely
what is going on here this is very
interesting
he's completely exposed maybe it's a
tiger we saw earlier yes here we go this
is going to be interesting it's a dunker
it's a doctor approaching no Kirsten he
can't see a dyke on the dam cam but he
can see a doctor here coming towards the
water to drink he's using the car he's
using the car as cover he's using the
car in front of us as cover the dacha is
thinking about coming for a drink this
is astounding we're not going to do an
unscheduled broadcast here simply
because he is using the vehicle as cover
which i think is unfortunately a
slightly unfair advantage conferred on
the cat the dike air moving away now I
think probably because we're sitting
here and no duiker will come this close
to us
but clearly he's thinking that that
would be quite nice to eat can't see the
doctor anymore the tail just tried to
tell the bird to shut up
he's peering out from behind the cheetah
planes and vehicles back a tire very
fixed and concentrated
now he's looking up towards the guest
cheater plains as if to say don't you
dare speak
don't you dare lift that I can o the
time here
I'm pretty sure that dykey would have
come to have a drink if it hadn't been
brass here there he is nice going on to
the back of the car to see it and can't
get himself a gin and tonic he's not
really doing that he's going to go round
and see let's see if we can't it's one
last look at him I don't want to move no
there we go what a magical cat look at
that nun a beautiful pose he is a poser
as well as being a clown alrighty let's
just we're gonna move around the side he
is seeking cover he is hunting this
darker let's just wait and see what he
does first from here
it's gonna give him a chance to see if
he can pick it up again I can't see the
dark of the stage
but we can still see the catch you can
still see house on us and just to stay
exactly where we are actually I think
this is fine
can't see the dacha he can I think
you can hear there's a great deal of
consternation on the vehicle in front of
us somebody's butt pins and needles in
their legs
we still got a nice picture of in might
I think we're gonna move shall we move a
little bit I'm just gonna put ourselves
in the middle over there I can still see
him
let's just put ourselves in the middle
yet we've got a long range line' so we
don't have to get very close but in
order to get me light on him with the
infrared we might have to be a little
bit closer right we're gonna stop over
here now I'm afraid everyone we don't
have the few year older citizens got the
FLIR on his car so we've just got our
eyes and infrared see if this thing
works probably not at this stage we have
got also an infrared torch which costs
are slightly more concentrated beam of
infrared light but he's not gonna work
at this distance we're just giving him
some space no idea where the tiger is I
think he does yes Eddie he does have
swagger I have to agree he's a show-off
basically
he's a clownish showoff now where's he
going
this is now not after the same prey
let's just see what he does for the next
two minutes
I don't think we'll extend the drive
because I tell you why I'm not gonna go
crashing in there after him that's a
beautiful shot though that we still have
there now he's still hunting the same
duiker he's trying to get around I still
see him there well done since all I
think that's perfect isn't it he's
losing concentration neither he's
looking at other things and there might
be an easier Quarry through there he's
definitely lost focused on this current
together hmm got something through there
it's probably a squirrel oh it's
attempting to move he disappears down
there we'll have to move
he's quite a distance from us now let's
go
so what he's done is he's gone over the
edge there this other duiker unless it's
crossed through here I don't think it
has
all of you wishing him well in his hunt
he's gone over down here
ease down the way I can't see the other
darker so if he is hunting add our coats
on the same one they said managed to
cross the road yeah I'm not gonna follow
him in there everybody he's obviously on
the hunt and you see him a man
oh my goodness well while we wait and
see if Hashanah pops out the Sidney has
a final surprise look at that I'm very
lucky with that ting gun I can see
Kangana is right here now trying to
relax next to my vehicle look at this
this is very beautiful he was doing some
hunting activities and I could see that
he was watching a hyena disappearing
just my right-hand side look at thing
Anna looking at my comb operator you can
see that the ears are very much worried
he is up to something
so Cheng Anna has been hiding in the
area where I've been during the day
looking for Tandy and Kalama this is a
lovely animal this is my favorite cat
here in humor look at that just going
right in the back of the vehicle
following the Einar look at that
slowly moving towards the side a good
afternoon all stations this is Sydney
I've got egg on a film as deep so right
there waiting a nice going his way I've
seen the high in a disappearing what
made me to seat in Ghana I was informed
by the hyena because I saw the hyena
going that side looking at the back
you can see that he is slowly moving
towards there he is interested on
something at the moment he is hiding
right behind the pole he's hunting thank
you very much for all your questions and
comments and let's meet tomorrow at half
past six
[Music]
you